cathy fin de la séance de chat et je
vais aller me faire un p'tit truc est
grimé en blanc tu m'emmènes attachement
ça va juste quelque chose en face de
chez nous chez les nouveaux voisins
c'est le fils des voisins d'en face
il s'appelle robin rsa m'arrête à
l'hôpital alors il va s'installer ici là
nulle part où aller
il n'y a pas d'autres familles j'en sais
rien j'ai jamais vu sa mère maman maman
je crois pas que c'était un accident
qu'est ce que tu dis en fait c'est trop
bizarre vous voulez que je vous montre
un truc trop stylé qu'on peut faire avec
la kinect
la kinect projette des points de
repérage des cétacés rendu battant robby
tu peux me dire à qui tu parlais
c'est quoi on dirait un triangle avec un
rond au milieu
tiens c'est ça ça veut dire quoi toi ils
t'aiment pas du tout qui jusque là bas
tu le sauras bien sûr wyatt il faut que
tu me dises qui se passe je veux pas
qu'on te fasse du mal
j'ai pas